No worries.
What's your all time favorite movie?
If you had a,
if there was one one move,
you smokey the bandit.
God Damn,
that's a good every time.
That's a good call.
And if I had to get an in depth and think about it,
I might go with stroker ace where the,
the giant I thing,
uh,
the smoke tower fell and he goes right under it because these guys were doing
their own stunts.
That shit was real.
That wasn't CGI.
I mean they were doing it.
What was that one movie with the girl?
Her name was domino.
Uh,
he was a detective called domino.
That was it called domino?
Yeah.
I don't remember who,
is that what it's called?
Or are we talking about with Burt Reynolds?
Yeah.
Well you know like the,
what's it called?
Domino Deron.
Cannonball Rem.
And they drove the car into the pool.
Like the Nascar looking thing.
Yeah,
they did that because they were fucking drunk.
They were loaded and they were partying and the camera's just happened to be
rolling that.
And that wasn't planned.
It wasn't part of the script.
They did it because I thought it was funny.
What is it called?
Sharkey's machine.
That's right.
God Damn,
what years?
That 81 I was 14 years old.
I remember watching this movie on TV.
I was like,
God damn,
I wish I was Burt Reynolds
and the woman who was like his girlfriend.
Oh my God,
she was so hot.
Look at her
leg warmer days and ethics.
That's when they,
yeah,
they had leg warmers back then and then no one had an ass.
They need figure out asses when they figured out acid sir.
Mix a lot ladies and gentlemen,
why people were in a daze.
We didn't even know what to ask was sir.
Mix a lot.
Came along and changed the game.
He came along with baby,
got back and we were like,
wait,
wait.
Oh my God,
that is better.
It was like everybody just got smelling salts under the nose.
Yeah.
And then the Kardashians fucked it up for all of us.
Everybody woke up.
They did,
but they didn't.
They exploited a whole new system.
You know like Jennifer Lopez had strong ass game way before them.
But it was a legit Latina ass game.
Correct.
From years of dancing and fucking running upstairs and shit.
Right?
Correct.
Whatever the fuck she did.
Well also,
she's like four foot two machine.
Yeah,
she's pretty short.
She's probably five foot one or something.
She's pretty short pack it all in small area.
He got to get it in.
But those movies,
man,
like Burt Reynolds movies for whatever deliverance doesn't get the respect it
deserves.
That is one of the all time greatest drama movies.
Absolutely.
Of all time.
I actually have a picture when I was filming with burden his house somewhere in
my phone,
I'll never find it.
But um,
I was in his memorabilia room,
which also doubled as his weight room and just,
there was stuff everywhere and I was texting the way I was dealing with a
problem and somebody snapped a picture of it and the deliverance,
a canoe is like laying up against the wall and there's all these different
memorabilia things in there.
And when I say remember be like that,
it was like a hoarding room.
There was just,
everything was in there and it was unbelievable.
It's like the most surreal thing cause I'm hammering away and there's like
everything behind you at that dude.
Here's the other thing about that movie,
and by the way,
Burt Reynolds,
University of Florida played football was a fucking dud.
Yeah.
That movie introduced me to the world of compound bows.
I didn't even know what a compound bow was until I saw that movie.
I don't know how to calm down.
Low is now for bow hunting,
bro.
I don't pro hunt,
man.
I ain't doing bell.
Ron Burt Reynolds Reynolds.
I was thinking a bow.
Hey Jackson,
need you to buy pro rentals.com of Jackson.
I was going to say it's also a big bow hunter,
but something about that movie.
Like when,
who was the guy who was getting fucked when they're like,
squeal,
like a pig.
What was his name?
The actor.
Ah,
yes.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Ned Beatty.
Thank you.
Ned Beatty got dams.
That guy.
Good actor.
Holy Shit.
You were so scared for him.